und dann gibt es da ein mädchen benennt
jetzt einfach mal lasst mich kurz
überlegen stadtteil etwas knapper netz
bekommen beim ein video und ich hab mir
grad einfach mal wieder dieses alberne
den kopf gemacht und ich weiß halt immer
noch nicht so auf der einen seite ist
von albern auf der anderen seite finde
ich auch cool so auch egal ich lasse es
jetzt einfach so so so so was ich
einfach sofort schon wieder stört euch
diese scheiß belichtung im fernseher
hinter mir das hat die gäste auch schon
das gibt's doch gar nicht das weckt das
ist weg das ist einfach weg naja ok ich
will gar nicht lange da wird auch wenn
ich schon wieder zu lange gelagert habe
ich weiß und wir kommen sofort auf den
punkt und zwar ist mir letztens
irgendwann ich glaub ich lag im bett da
ist mir die idee auf dieses video
gekommen weil ich mir so gedacht hast
kommen die jungs sind eigentlich schon
total blöd und verstehen so oft einfach
dinge falsch natürlich versteht das ein
oder andere mädchen auch ab und zu mal
dinge falsch aber ich glaube schon dass
jungs sogar mit abstand an der spitze
stehen was falsch verstehen angeht und
deswegen geht es im heutigen video darum
was mädchen machen und jungs immer also
meistens ich sag jetzt einfach mal immer
falsch verstehen und an die ganzen
moralapostel jetzt wieder um die ecke
kommen und sagen ob es ist doch nicht
wieder jugend gleich so natürlich
erzählt natürlich den ein oder anderen
jungen geben der nicht so denkt bei dem
und dem punkt aber der großteil ist so
das ist einfach so ich meine wenn es
nicht so ist dann bin ich scheiße keine
ahnung ist es so halten helfer ihr wisst
was ich meine ich würde sagen wir fangen
an weil ich auch mal bock gehabt aus was
mädchen evers jungs machen und mädchen
immer falsch verstehen beziehungsweise
meistens falsch verstehen dann euch
natürlich erstmal eure kommentare als
wenn du jetzt ein mädchen ist schreibt
auch in die kommentare was du was
verstehst oder was du denkst du stehst
du merfeld und ihr könnt ihr schon mal
kräftig die daumen nach oben da lassen
dann sehe ich das ja und jetzt geht's
los ich glaub ich fange erst mal mit dem
schlimmsten oder mit einem der
schlimmsten punkte für uns jungs an wenn
man dann doch denkt oder merkt halt
das war vielleicht doch nicht so und
zwar folgen es gibt ja wirklich sehr
sehr viele total nette mädchen also die
wirklich total sympathisch und nett sind
zu sehen
in person und es gibt auch ein paar
mädchen diese nicht so nett aber wir
beziehen uns jetzt erstmal auf die
mädchen die sind voll und dann gibt es
da ein mädchen bin jetzt einfach mal
lasst mich gut zu überlegen scheint teil
was habe ich schon wieder heute alter
auf jeden fall haben jetzt einmal schon
teil
und wir haben einmal alex meinetwegen
ich bin alex und chantal ist wirklich
sehr sehr nett zu alex und keine ahnung
ihr wisst ja so man ist einfach eine zu
dieser person also scheint alles nett zu
mir und alex denkt sich so body ist ja
echt nett zu mir ist ja voll cool nur
das ding ist was wirklich sehr sehr
viele jungs dann immer falsch verstehen
ist wenn ein mädchen ziemlich nett zu
ihm selber ist dann denkt der junge
wirklich immer so moratti fährt voll auf
mich ab oder steht auf mich und der
junge denkt genau ja die ist ja
vielleicht auch ganz hübsch
also ich glaub schon dass jungstar was
rein interpretieren in nette mädchen als
mädchen in nette jung versteht ihr was
ich meine ist kann natürlich auch sein
dass es andersrum ähnliches aber ich
glaube schon dass das bei uns so ihr
wisst was ich meine oder ja und darauf
kann man glaube ich auf den nächsten
punkt direkt übertragen weil wir nehmen
jetzt einfach mal instagram so als
beispiel wenn ihr mir da noch nicht voll
gemacht dass alex wie einfach so ab also
stellt euch vor wir haben jetzt
instagram social network hey was also
stellt euch vor wir haben jetzt einfach
instagram das ist ein social network ja
sehr gut erkannt alexander und ein
mädchen leicht zu 67 8 bilder von dem
jungen dann denkt der junge eigentlich
sofort immer sofort die findet mich
bestimmt hübsch oder steht auf mich
anders herum wenn halt ein junger so
fünf sechs sieben bilder von dem mädchen
leicht denke ich mal denkt das mädchen
war der findet mich nur geil und will
mich durch aber ich glaube da finde ich
es auch schade dass die meisten mädchen
an so denken weil die jungs sind gar
nicht immer so gesteuert sondern finden
mädchen auch oftmals sah ich mal wenn
ich jetzt zum beispiel als ich noch
keine freunde habt und 56 bilder von
einem anderen mädchen durch geleitet
habe finde ich sie hübsch so ach komm
wir lassen uns ganz so leichte punkt
nummer drei
und zwar alle warum warum gehe ich immer
von mir aus wir haben jetzt einfach ein
junge und ein mädchen und die schreiben
so miteinander über web und vor dem
mädchen kommt dann irgendwann einfach
als antwort okay also nicht okay sondern
einfach ok sieht von albers man schon
besser oder ist so besser oder mit
schreibt in die kommentare auf jeden
fall kommt als antwort okay also nur
eine note 1 kam nicht okay sondern nur
ok und der junge denkt sich dann so ab
dann ist ja alles okay aber
irgendwie ist nicht alles okay auch wenn
ich nicht weiß warum man dann okay
schreibt aber das ist halt einfach so
einfach so wenn ich raus okay leute
bevor wir zum letzten punkt kommen den
ich wirklich heiss wird euch diskutieren
möchte und auch gar nicht weiß ob das so
stimmt oder nicht kommen wir erst mal zu
punkt 4 sind wir glaube ich und zwar
wenn man eine freundin hat also wirklich
mit einer person in einer beziehung drin
ist und die freundin von den jungen so
plötzlich ein baby so richtig süß findet
und somit dem spiel des oas voll süß ist
so sind ja dann milch und meistens war
dann denkt der junge so scheiße
welches kind das war jetzt auch
eventuell seinen gedankengang von mir
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob es bei jedem so
ist aber ich glaube bei vielen schuld
und jetzt kommt's mir wirklich zum
letzten punkt den ich irgendwie mal mit
euch zu sprechen musste mir das auch so
eingefallen ist und ich will damit jetzt
auch gar keine mädchen ein reifen oder
so weil das betrifft auch nicht viele
mädchen sondern nur ein bruchteil sag
ich mal
aber das ist mir halt mal so im kopf
herumgeschwirrt und zwar wenn ein junge
mit mädchen schreibt und das mädchen
heißt du irgendwie sage ich mal heiße
bilder schickt oder sucht dann denken
glaube ich viele jungs so boldt die will
ja eigentlich nur das eine ist ja voll
cool obwohl sie doch auf den jungen
steht also noch mal das sollte jetzt
keinen von euch da draußen angreift
manuals grad als mädchen des videos
schaust du das betrifft dich
wahrscheinlich nicht mal es war also ein
gedankengang von mir deswegen streit
dazu doch mal einfach eure meinung in
die kommentare es interessiert mich
wirklich sehr also ist es so oder ist es
eher nicht so keine ahnung ansonsten
hoffe ich das video hat euch gefallen
und ja ich habe einfach mal gedacht
macht mal wieder so ein video ich hab
das ja früher sehr oft gemacht und jetzt
habe ich wieder lust zu ihr könnt ja mal
weitere themen oder so auch in dem
kommentar schreiben was sie gerne von
mir bequatscht haben wollte in diese
mädchen jungs richtung weil ich derzeit
wieder butt bleibt ansonsten hofft dass
wieder deutlich gefallen habe ich glaube
ich schon gesagt lass nach oben da und
ja wir sehen uns dann morgen denke ich
mal wieder bei ihm ein video morgen
gegen 18 19 uhr kommt eine neue ausgabe
musicals zum fremdschämen weil ich da
auch mal wieder lust zu haben
und ja das war's dann fürs zuschauen
aber nie vergessen wir sind bei 420.000
und wies